[Musique]
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
la séance est reprise l'ordre du jour
appelle l'examen des conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire chargée
d'élaborer un texte sur les dispositions
restant en discussion du projet de loi
de finances rectificative pour 2022
avant cela la parole est au président
claude raynal
oui bonjour monsieur le ministre
merci de nous rejoindre après un débat à
l'assemblée qui a été un petit peu long
on va dire heureux de vous retrouver
pour cette ses conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire qui a était
donc conclusive
hier soir nous étions en commission
mixte paritaire et ce même jour le matin
nous apprenions que la loi de règlement
n'était pas validé et donc ma simple
interrogation lorsque vous prendrez la
parole sera juste d'avoir une
information pour savoir comment cela se
passe et comment le gouvernement entend
procéder dans les mois qui viennent
éventuellement merci merci monsieur le
ministre
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président d'abord je voudrais saluer la
constance du sénat qui en première comme
en deuxième lecture à rejeter le projet
de loi de règlement alors même qu'à
l'assemblée nationale on a vu un petit
peu plus d'hésitation avec tout d'abord
une adoption puis un rejet de ce projet
de loi de règlement et vos questions
sont légitimes d'abord souligner que
nous avons eues à l'assemblée nationale
comme au sénat des débats très
approfondie sur ce projet de loi de
règlement le débat a lieu souligné
ensuite que le rejet de ce projet de loi
de règlement n'en portent pas de
conséquence sur l'exécution du budget du
projet doit de finale de la loi de
finances 2022 ni sûr
le projet de loi de finances 2010 23 et
que sur ce sujet vous pouvez être
rassurés et vous dire enfin que
effectivement la question d'un nouveau
dépôt se pose notamment pour arrêter les
comptes en comptabilité générale et les
affecter aux bilans de l'état en vue de
faciliter la certification des comptes
par la cour des comptes et à ce stade
l'opportunité juridique et comptable
d'un nouveau dépôt fait l'objet d'une
étude d'un travail d'investigations de
la part du gouvernement
merci monsieur le ministre nous
reprenons donc sur la lecture des
conclusions la parole est un monsieur
jean françois husson rapporteur pour le
sénat de la commission mixte paritaire
pour cinq minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
vous le savez les conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire qui s'est
tenue hier au sénat ont abouti à un
accord je m'en félicite ou non notre
assemblée je veux rappeler les trois
priorités auxquelles nous étions
parfaitement attaché d'abord
l'attachement à la valeur travail
concrètement consacré par nos décisions
deuxièmement le soutien aux
collectivités locales acteurs de
proximité reconnu et apprécié dans la
mise en oeuvre des services quotidiens
pour nos concitoyens et enfin un arrêt
de la dégradation de nos comptes publics
tout d'abord le la valeur travail est
reconnue et soutenue dans un contexte de
retour de l'inflation qui pèse à la fois
sur les ménages et malheureusement sur
les entreprises à travers la pénurie de
main d'oeuvre et bien pour continuer à
soutenir les salariés et offrir de la
souplesse aux entreprises dans la
gestion du temps de travail notre cmp a
d'abord confirmé la
pérennisation proposée par le sénat en
portant de 5000 à 7500 euros le plafond
applicable à la défiscalisation des
heures supplémentaires la commission
mixte a étendu jusqu'au 31 décembre 2025
la possibilité offerte aux salariés avec
accord de l'employeur de convertir en
majoration de salaire tout ou partie des
journées ou demi journée de rtt non
prise et enfin inciter tous les
employeurs pour 2022 est 2023 à
participer d'avantagé sur la base du
volontariat à la prise en charge des
abonnements de transport de leurs
salariés à hauteur de 50 % du coût et en
exonérant fiscalement et socialement la
fraction en allant jusqu'à 75 % elle a
aussi et je crois que c'est important de
dire tout de suite accordé et c'est
aussi accordés sur la nécessité
d'allouer n'est qu'une aide
exceptionnelle de rentrée à tous les
bénéficiaires de la prime d'activité au
même titre que les allocataires des
minima sociaux
en termes de soutien au pouvoir d'achat
il convient de rappeler que beaucoup a
été fait est adopté par le sénat que ce
soit en première lecture le maintien du
bouclier tarifaire sur l'énergie les
aides sur le chauffage au fuel et les
modalités de remise sur le carburant j
ajoute des mesures destiné à alléger le
coût des transports pour les ça rires
pour répondre également aux besoins
immédiats des plus démunis la cmp a
confirmé les 40 millions d'euros votée à
l'initiative et à l'unanimité à
l'initiative du sénat à destination des
associations d'aidé alimentaire soumise
à d'importantes difficultés
d'approvisionnement pour permettre à
tous les français de pouvoir chaque jour
se nourrir ensuite le sénat s'est engagé
à garantir aux collectivités
territoriales les moyens de ses actions
c'est bien sûr la confirmation et la
compensation de la revalorisation du rsa
prévue pour les départements à
l'assemblée nationale votait d'ailleurs
à l'assemblée nationale est maintenu en
l'état au sénat mais c'est aussi la
compensation pour les régions au titre
de la revalorisation de la rémunération
des stagiaires en formation
professionnelle et nous avons renforcé
le filet de sécurité introduit à
l'assemblée nationale nous inscrivant
dans leurs pas pour les communes et les
groupements
deux communes les plus fragiles et c'est
financièrement ce qui a fait multiplier
par trois le nombre de bénéficiaires en
insistant non seulement pour garantir
50% de la réalisation du point à 10 mais
également en améliorant à hauteur de 70%
la prise en compte des coûts de
l'énergie et de l'alimentation
ce qui s'est traduit je le dis par un
vote unanime sur ce sujet hier en
commission mixte paritaire
il n'y a donc pas de polémique dont le
soutien à apporter aux collectivités
locales
ensuite et enfin
ce
plfr et le plfr qui doit nous faire
prendre conscience
définitivement de la rigueur et de la
sobriété budgétaire dont le parlement et
l'exécutif
doit faire preuve
dégradation des comptes publics dont ils
font je crois et je nous invite à en
prendre conscience
signalez signé la fin de la partie
raison pour laquelle nous vous invitons
sur la base de cet accord dont je veux
remercier nos collègues députés et
confirmée le choix du sénat un travail
collectif une nouvelle manière de faire
pour l'exécutif est une habitude pour ce
qui concerne le choix du sénat de la
sagesse je vous invite donc à adopter ce
projet de loi de finances rectificative
je vous remercie merci merci monsieur le
rapporteur général la parole est
maintenant monsieur jean-noël barrot au
ministre délégué chargé de la transition
numérique et des télécommunications vous
avez la parole monsieur le ministre
monsieur le président monsieur le
président de la commission des finances
monsieur le rapporteur général mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs après
l'adoption définitive hier du premier
texte du paquet pouvoir d'achat nous
voilà réunis aujourd'hui pour je le
souhaite l'adoption du second texte
puisque le rapporteur général vient de
le dire la commission mixte paritaire
sur le plfr qui s'est réuni hier soir a
été conclu bruno le maire l'a dit ce
matin c'est une triple victoire une
victoire pour les français qui pourront
mieux faire face à l'augmentation des
prix une victoire de la politique du
compromis une victoire pour les finances
publiques qui ont été tenus ce plfr a
été examiné par le parlement après la
publication des derniers résultats de
l'économie française avec un chiffre de
croissance de +0 5% pour le deuxième
trimestre la france obtient l'un des
meilleurs résultats de la zone euro ceci
prouve que l'économie française résiste
et résiste même mieux que les autres
économies européennes et que l'économie
française atteindra les 2 5% de
croissance en 2022 comme annoncé par le
gouvernement par la voix de bruno le
maire c'est une victoire obtenue dans
des temps difficiles
vous le savez nous sommes dans le pic
inflationniste
cette inflation restera probablement à
un niveau élevé jusqu'à la fin de
l'année 2022 nous avons cependant de
bonnes raisons d'espérer une baisse de
celle ci court en 2023 j'y reviendrai un
peu plus tard il s'agit donc d'un cap à
passer et avec ce paquet pouvoir d'achat
nous prenons toutes les mesures
nécessaires pour accompagner nos
compatriotes dans cette période
grâce à l'accord trouvé en cmp nous
maintiendrons le bouclier énergie
jusqu'à la fin de l'année 2022 avec le
gel des prix du gaz d'une part le
plafonnement de la hausse du prix de
l'électricité à 4% d'autre part alors
que je le rappelle celle ci aurait été
de 45% sans notre intervention
ce bouclier énergie nous permis d'avoir
les taux d'inflation le plus faible de
la zone euro en effet et vous le savez
déjà
l'inflation est tirée à 50 % par le seul
prix de l'énergie je veux vous redire au
nom du gouvernement que nous
continuerons également
nous battre au niveau européen pour
dissocier définitivement le prix de
l'électricité décarbonés du prix du gaz
nous avons par ailleurs trouver un
compromis sur le fuel le rapporteur
général l'a rappelé il comprend
l'adoption du net de 230 millions
d'euros pour les ménages qui utilisent
ce combustible pour se chauffer nous
proposons d'associer les parlementaires
de l'assemblée nationale et du sénat au
ciblage des ménages qui pourront
bénéficier de cette aide supplémentaire
jusqu'à trois millions de ménages
français seront concernés
nous allons faire passer la ristourne
sur les carburants à 30 centimes d'euro
en septembre 30 centimes en octobre 10
centimes en novembre et 10 centimes en
décembre pour les français qui
travaillent d'autres dispositifs seront
mis en place nous avons voté le
doublement du plafond d'exonération de
l'actrims carburant versées par les
employeurs de 200 400 euros nous allons
aussi permettre son cumul avec la prise
en charge de l'abonnement transport
collectif nous avions par ailleurs déjà
revalorisé de 10% le barème kilométrique
de l'impôt sur le revenu en 2022 nous
sommes prêts à leur valoriser de nouveau
en 2023 ce plfr vise également à rendre
du pouvoir d'achat aux françaises et aux
français par la valorisation de leur
travail et je sais combien vous y êtes
sensible la mesure de monétisation des
rtt permettra aux salariés qui le
souhaitent de travailler plus afin
d'augmenter leur rémunération dans des
conditions fiscales avantageuses
concernant la défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires
le relèvement du plafond d'exonération
fiscale de 5000 à 7500 euros est une
bonne chose et grâce au sénat cette
mesure devient pérenne enfin grâce aux
discussions entre l'assemblée nationale
et le sénat les entreprises de 20 à 250
salariés vont voir leurs charges
sociales patronales réduite de 50
centimes par heure supplémentaire
travaillée je veux remercier ici le
président retailleau qui a porté ce
sujet notamment je suis ici devant
l'assemblée des collectivités locales je
sais que l'inflation et que les
revalorisations engagés peuvent susciter
des inquiétudes
à l'initiative de madame christine pires
bonne les députés en date adopté à une
large majorité le dispositif suivant
d'abord 180 millions d'euros de crédits
ciblées s'adresser aux plus de 6000
communes en difficulté dans ce qu'elle
peine à faire face à la hausse du prix
de l'énergie est à la hausse du point
d'indicé les collectivités d'outre-mer
sont particulièrement concernés et je
sais que vous y êtes sensibles ens 820
millions d'euros pour compenser la
hausse du rsa au niveau des départements
au sénat un nouveau compromis a été
trouvé grâce au rapporteur général et je
veux également salué le travail du
président françois patriat et du
président hervé marseille sur ce sujet
et ce sont ainsi près de 22000
collectivités qui vont finalement
bénéficié de ce filet de sécurité
durant nos débats l'idée de taxer les
surprofits est arrivé comme à
l'assemblée nationale cette idée de taxe
a été rejeté par la haute assemblée et
je tiens à saluer la sagesse du sénat
bruno le maire l'a dit alors que nos
compatriotes souffrent de la vie chère
nous partageons tous l'idée selon
laquelle chacun doit porter une part du
fardeau de l'inflation l'état bien sûr
qu'il le fait déjà
les ménages qui sont contraints avec
l'augmentation des prix alimentaires et
des prix des carburants bien sûr les
entreprises aussi nous ne contestons pas
ce raisonnement mais l'immense majorité
des entreprises souffrent de l'inflation
elles sont de toutes tailles grandes
entreprises au pays pme tpe dans tous
les sectes les entreprises du bâtiment
et des transports par exemple sont lésés
par l'augmentation du prix des matières
premières les entreprises de
l'hôtellerie de la restauration de la
distribution quand elles sont lourdement
pénalisés par le manque de main d'oeuvre
beaucoup d'entreprises participent en
réalité déjà à la lutte contre la vie
chère en augmentant les salaires bruno
le maire a encore rappelé ce matin
toutes celles et toutes celles des
entreprises qui ne l'ont pas fait à ce
stade à agir dans ce sens mais celles
qui ne le peuvent pas peuvent agir
autrement justement ce saisissant des
outils que vous avez voté cet été prime
exceptionnelle de pouvoir d'achat
intéressement participation
en revanche quelques entreprises font
des bénéfices importants c'est vrai
elles doivent participer à l'effort
collectif à l'image de la remise de 20
centimes à la pompe pour total de la
baisse du prix des conteneurs pour
s'aimer cm1 cgm ou encore du chèque
énergie pour angie cette approche est
tout simplement plus juste plus efficace
et plus conforme à vos aspirations pour
nos territoires plus juste car elle ne
pénalise pas les entreprises qui ont
besoin d'investir pour l'avenir et la
pérennité de l'emploi plus efficace car
l'argent va directement dans les poches
de nos compatriotes 20 centimes de
remise à la pompe cela amène le litre de
carburant à 1 euro 50 une fois combinés
avec la ristourne que vous avez voté
plus conforme à vos aspirations qu'elle
va dans le sens de la baisse des impôts
qui est notre ligne et favorise
l'attractivité de notre territoire et de
tous nos territoires du point de vue des
finances publiques nous observons qu'en
baissant les impôts nous obtenons plus
de recettes fiscales je pense par
exemple à la baisse de notre impôt sur
les sociétés qui s'est accompagnée
accompagnée d'une augmentation de son
produit entre 2017 et 2022 en libérant
de la capacité à investir nous avons
permis à nos entreprises de créer plus
de richesse c'est un fait enfin ce plfr
avec la suppression de la contribution
sur l'audiovisuel public qui rendra 138
euros de pouvoir d'achat aux ménages
cette décision est conforme à notre
politique de baisse des impôts à
laquelle les sénateurs sont attachés je
le crois
l'assemblée nationale a travaillé un
dispositif de financement durable de
l'audiovisuel public gage défendre
l'indépendance
tâchons de poursuivre ce dialogue
constructif pour conclure comme je les
dis en début de propos ce paquet pouvoir
d'achat arrivent au bon moment puisque
il aidera nos compatriotes à passer ce
cap difficile et je reste confiant de
capacités collectives en france et en
europe à ramener l'inflation à un taux
raisonnable dans le courant de l'année
2023 nous pouvons compter sur les
mesures prises par la banque centrale
européenne sur la politique monétaire
nous agissons surtout chaque jour par
les mesures que nous prenons en matière
d'énergie et de diversification de nos
approvisionnements en mai dernier les
françaises et les français ont réélu
emmanuel macron président de la
république fin juin ils ont également
voulu marquer une autre volonté celle de
voir les différences forces du politique
du pays trouver des compromis dialoguer
sur les textes de loi nous voulons le
faire en un mois à peine et nous avons
fait la démonstration que ces compromis
sont possibles nous avons appris de
cette première étape est le gouvernement
souhaite que nous puissions continuer
dans cette voie au service de nos
compatriotes toujours je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre
je rappelle qu'en application de
l'article 42 alinéa 12 du règlement le
sénat examine à après l'assemblée
nationale le texte élaboré par la
commission mixte paritaire
il se prononce par un seul vote sur
l'ensemble de ce texte en ne retenant
que les amendements présentés ou
acceptés par le gouvernement
en conséquence le vote sur les
amendements et sur les articles est
réservé aux passions monsieur le
ministre à la présentation des quatre
amendements du gouvernement sur le
projet de loi de finances rectificative
pour 2022 avant d'en venir aux
explications de vote des groupes vous
avez la parole monsieur le ministre
a d'abord monsieur le président si vous
me permettez je vous propose de les
présenter d'un seul bloc merci monsieur
le président sur ces quatre amendements
3 qui lève les gages du dispositif que
vous avez adopté hier en commission
mixte paritaire
10 millions d'euros pour lever le gage
de l'amendement du sénateur roues visant
à soutenir la production de lavande et
de lavandin 5 millions d'euros pour
lever le gage de l'amendement du
rapporteur général pour soutenir les 600
millions d'euros enfin pour lever le
gage de l'amendement de la commission
mixte paritaire visant à étendre l'aide
exceptionnelle de rentrer aux
bénéficiaires de la prime d'activité
enfin l'amendement numéro 4 mai à jour
l'article d'équilibré conséquent de
l'accord trouvé en cmp
merci monsieur le ministre avis de la
commission
c'est un avis favorable et j'en profite
pour remercier le ministre est
évidemment à travers lui le gouvernement
mais les ministres en charge des ruelles
attal et bruno le maire pour avoir
permis non seulement d'aboutir mais
également très concrètement d'avoir
accepté de lever le gage ceci étant avec
un accord sortie de commissions mixtes
paritaires je n'ose je n'aurais osé
imaginer qu'il en fût autrement mais
quand même un très grand merci ça va
nous permettre de passer quelques jours
de vacances je ne sais pas si elles sont
bien et je pense que si mais surtout
l'esprit un peu plus tranquille le
porte-monnaie peut-être pas mais
l'esprit certainement
merci monsieur le rapporteur général
nous passons aux explications de vote
des groupes pas raison d'un orateur par
hope la parole est au président alain
richard pour le gault père des pays pour
cinq minutes
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues voilà donc un projet de
loi dont nous allons maintenant adopté
les termes débattue dans un calendrier
rigoureux entre deux bornes d'une part
la reprise des travaux parlementaires
après l'élection de l'assemblée
nationale d'autre part la nécessité
d'avoir des mesures urgentes pour aider
les français et les acteurs économiques
à surmonter les facteurs de l'inflation
qui nous pressent
le gouvernement
je vous suggère de mentionner auprès de
vos collègues monsieur le ministre a été
à la fois responsable et à l'ecoute il a
trouvé des partenaires de dialogue au
parlement chez ceux qui le soutiennent
et aussi chez bien d'autres
nous avons et je pense tout ce qui se
prépare à adopter ce projet de loi
partage cet avis nous avons été
attentifs à léquilibre ressources
dépenses de l'état nous avons refusé le
dérapage qui menaçait dans la
consolidation en cours d'aidé des
comptes publics et je crois que nous
sommes nombreux à souhaiter que au terme
de cette consolidation nous sortions
définitivement de la mauvaise habitude
consistant à financer des dépenses de
fonctionnement et de solidarité avec des
emprunts
dans ce plfr nous sion je crois quatre
objectifs simples prendre en compte la
situation des plus faibles revenus face
à l'inflation donc augmentation des
minima sociaux et du smic mais dans ce
projet l'aide exceptionnelle de rentrée
et le soutien aux associations d'aidé
alimentaire ensuite soutenir le revenu
l'activité
et donc ça se traduit outre donc les
revalorisations salariales par la
revalorisation des exonérations de
titres restaurant l'exonération fiscale
améliorée de 50 % des heures
supplémentaires la compensation
partielle en monétaire des rtt mais qui
au fond est assez l'équivalent pour les
bénéficiaires de rtt de la l'exonération
des heures supplémentaires et ce pour
une période de trois ans en revanche et
je sais que ça a donné lieu à d des
interventions critiques il n'y avait pas
de mesures salariales générales lander
de la hausse du smic parce que il faut
répéter et se convaincre surtout les
bons je crois que c'est la
responsabilité des entreprises et des
employeurs qui ne peut pas y avoir de
proclamation unilatérale de l'état en
régime de l'économie de marché pour
fixer les salaires depuis le haut sans
tenir compte des nécessités de chaque
entreprise et je dirais surtout ce
serait d'autant plus contraire à la
réalité dans une période de tensions sur
le marché du travail qui paraît même va
déclencher une certaine dynamique des
salaires est à dire dans bien des
secteurs c'est commencer il y avait
ensuite troisième point des mesures
favorables à l'action climatique et je
salue en particulier l'aide aux
investissements des pme en efficacité
énergétique de soutien au covoiturage le
forfait l'amélioration du forfait
mobilité durable et puis enfin dernier
point et je me lis tout à fait dans le
propos du rapporteur général un soutien
adapté aux collectivités locales pour
passer le cap des surcharges qui n'était
évidemment pas incluse dans l'est dans
les budgets primitifs un dispositif dont
on dira le fait uniquement qu'il a bien
progressé depuis le départ du projet de
loi monsieur nourrissent puisque on
partait de zéro
nos collègues de l'assemblée à
l'initiative en particulier d'une
collègue du groupe socialiste a entamé
le projet mais nous étions nombreux et
plusieurs responsables de groupes en
débat ont insisté sur ce point pour
souligner qu'ils avaient pas de grandes
divisions entre les communes face à
cette difficulté que la majorité des
communes avait en gros le même impact
parce qu'elle dépense tous l es pensent
tout de l'énergie pour leur parc
automobile
pour l'heure leurs bâtiments qui sont
nombreux et pour l'éclairage public et
donc il ne fallait pas faire trop de
discriminations entre les collectivités
il fallait adopter des critères large
c'est ce qui a été fait je crois que
nous en sommes satisfaits pas seulement
sous un angle politique et d'équité mais
aussi avec une préoccupation
de dynamique économique parce que nous
savions tous nous l'entendions circulant
des semaines les autres dans nos vies et
nos collègues des communes que la seule
façon d'ajuster des collectes dans les
communes si il y avait aucune aide
budgétaire c'était simplement de retards
d investissements
donc je crois que nous avons bien fait
de nous en sortir de cette façon nous
sortons donc d'un dialogue qui a été à
la fois loyal et réaliste entre tous
ceux qui voulaient contribuer et
constructivement et qui ont pu se faire
entendre donc il faut remercier les
rapporteurs les collègues députés et
bien sûr les ministres et tous les
groupes d'avoir pu mener ce dialogue
constructif et responsable il ya dans ce
plf aidants sont dans ces débats
plusieurs rendez-vous pris pour les la
loi de finances 2023 l'urgence cette
fois ci se justifiera moins bien que
nous sachions ça les autres qu'un projet
de loi de finances quand il arrive à la
fin du mois d'août il est quand même
déjà bien mature et conclure monsieur le
président c'est comme si c'était fait
monsieur le président je crois donc
qu'on ne peut qu encourager le
gouvernement à rester dans cette
démarche qui a été recommandé par la
première ministre d'avoir le maximum
d'écouté et de dialogue mais en
attendant nous votons avec satisfaction
comme beaucoup ici ce soir ce projet de
loi merci la parole est maintenant pour
cinq minutes au président claude
malhuret pour les indépendants
le président ministre monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues il y à 2
133 ans jour pour jour le 4 août 1789
l'assemblée constituante avolys et les
privilèges ce qui devrait pouvoir
prouver aux esprits chagrins que le
parlement peut voter des textes
importants en plein été et même en
pleine nuit c'est le cas aujourd'hui
toutes proportions gardées bien sûr avec
l'adoption du paquet pouvoir d'achat qui
vise à atténuer les violences effets de
l'inflation sur nos concitoyens le sujet
était aussi complexe que sensible je
crois que nous sommes parvenus à un
texte équilibré qui comporte de me
nombreuses mesures concrètes dont les
français mesureront vite les pleins
effets c'est ce qu'ils attendaient de
nous c'est ce que nous avons fait en la
matière les remèdes miracles n'existent
pas tout est question d'équilibré et de
dosage augmenter le pouvoir d'achat sans
doper l'inflation hausse et les
rémunérations sont baissées la
compétitivité et surtout surtout ne pas
creuser le déficit public il y a
quelques années quelques mois encore les
économistes débattent et dans le confort
de leur chère avec un noeud pour savoir
si l'inflation appartenait à l'histoire
ancienne par empirisme ou par dogmatisme
il soutenait qu'elle avait disparu de
nos contrées comme jadis la peste ou les
tyrannies
c'était avant 2020 puis il ya eu la
pandémie
puis le confinement généralisée
puis la reprise économique dopée par un
keynésianisme sous stéroïdes puis un
choc de demande sans augmentations
d'offre et enfin le grand retour de
l'inflation et il y a eu surtout le
retour de la guerre en europe la folie
meurtrière du boucher du kremlin sa
haine obsessionnelle de la démocratie et
de la liberté
la donne changeait rien n'indique que
les choses rentreront bientôt dans
l'ordre le jusqu'au boutisme de l'ex
colonel du kgb contre la résistance
héroïque des ukrainiens les risques de
famine qui pèsent sur l'afrique par sa
faute les menaces de la chine sur taïwan
les populismes qui gangrènent l'europe
sont autant de menaces qui impose la
plus grande vigilance
ce monde inquiétant de nous donner le
courage et l'ambition de poursuivre nos
efforts pour renforcer la souveraineté
nationale et de mettre en profite ce
budget rectificatif le premier du
quinquennat qui s'ouvre pour lancer
quelques réformes importantes ce fut le
cas sur la question très sensible au
sénat des surcoûts liés et l'inflation
est supporté par les collectivités leur
compensation par l'état le point
d'équilibré trouvé entre le gouvernement
et le sénat prévoit une juste
répartition du fardeau entre état et
collectivités tant sur les dépenses
liées au rsa que sur celles qui
dépendent du point d indice ce budget
revalorise également le travail en
activant plusieurs leviers fiscaux qui
porteront rapidement leurs fruits je
pense notamment à la défiscalisation des
heures supplémentaires nous sommes
nombreux ici à soutenir de longue date
cette mesure dans la même logique la
possibilité donnée aux salariés de
racheter leurs rtt doit leur permettre
d'augmenter leur rémunération par le
travail n'en déplaise à ceux qui hurlent
à la casse sociale et à la fin des 35
heures c'est 35 heures qui ont précipité
notre déclassement et qui préfigurait
l'incroyable allergie au travail qui
s'abat depuis quelques mois sur tant de
nos concitoyens
si sûrement une telle mesure pouvait
nous permettre de rompre pour de bon
avec l'illusion tenace selon laquelle le
travail est un gâteau à partager à parts
égales
ce texte serait un pas dans la direction
du redressement national
le président de la république à l'instar
d'un de ses prédécesseurs nous a
récemment rappelé à l'évidence pour
financer notre modèle social garantir
notre souveraineté économique et
accélérer la transition écologique
il nous faudra travailler plus le sénat
est prêt à le soutenir pour oeuvrer dans
ce sens j'espère que nous serons au
rendez vous pour soutenir les mesures
difficiles mais nécessaires au
rétablissement des finances publiques
nous avons suivi le gouvernement dans sa
volonté de ne pas céder à la facilité
des contributions exceptionnelles taxes
extraordinaires et autres innovations
fiscale qui s'inscrirait dans le droit
fil de la pratique qui nous ronge depuis
des années et que j'ai déjà dénoncé ici
tout ce qui bouge on le taxe tout ce qui
bouge encore en le règlement tout ce qui
ne bouge plus on le subventionnent pour
désendetter l'état dans le pays champion
du monde des prélèvements obligatoires
l'alternative entre baisser les dépenses
et augmenter les taxes n'existe pas il
faut baisser les dépenses et comme
l'inflation pousse les taux d'intérêt à
la hausse nous allons redécouvrir que
s'endetter à un coût que nous ne pouvons
plus nous permettre sans renoncer à des
priorités essentielles
le quoi qu'il en coûte nous a permis de
tenir bon et de surmonter la crise
sanitaire économique et social il était
nécessaire mais il faut désormais
remettre de l'ordre dans nos comptes
pour nous préparer aux défis qui
s'annoncent je vous remercie merci la
parole est maintenant monsieur vincent
segouin pour le groupe l'est républicain
pour cinq minutes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur général monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues la cmp qui s'est
réuni hier soir est parvenu un très bon
accord sur le texte particulièrement
important qui vise la protection du
pouvoir d'achat de nos compatriotes
les débats ont été longs intense et on
se croit permis à tous les groupes de
défendre leurs propositions pour
soutenir les français marqué par la
hausse de l'inflation pour ce qui
concerne le groupe des républicains
notre ligne a été très clair le soutien
du pouvoir d'achat des ménages passent
d'abord par la valeur du travail et
certainement pas avec des chèques
temporaire financée par de la dette
dans cet esprit nous avons porté et fait
adopter des mesures puissante pour
arrêter définitivement la fin des 35
heures signe d'approuver
d'appauvrissement des français et
d'affaiblissement de notre économie
c'est le cas avec la pérennisation des
heures supplémentaires défiscalisées
inscrite dans le texte de la cmp
c'est également le cas avec le rachat
optionnel de rtt rendues possibles
jusqu'en fin 2025 en espérant que cette
mesure devienne pérenne c'est un signe
de responsabilisation et de liberté
offerte aux salariés cadres et non
cadres qui permettra un complément de
revenus importants par ses votes
le sénat a également envoyé des messages
très forts aux collectivités qui font
face à un coût de l'énergie de
l'alimentation de plus en plus élevés et
qu'ils doivent subir la hausse du point
d'indicé de la fonction publique la
majorité sénatoriale est parvenu avec le
gouvernement un accord ambitieux en
séance cet accord a été confirmé en cmp
je m'en félicite demain plus de la
moitié des communes françaises pourront
bénéficier d'une dotation exceptionnelle
pour tenir durant cette période
compliquée
je me réjouis également de l'adoption
conforme par nos deux chambres de la
compensation intégrale de la hausse du
rsa pour les départements et nous
n'avons pas oublié les régions qui
bénéficieront d'une compensation pour la
revalorisation des rémunérations versées
aux stagiaires de la formation
professionnelle
sur la proposition de notre rapporteur
général que je remercie pour leur
travail réalisé pour sa pugnacité nous
avons complété plusieurs dispositifs
initialement proposé je pense au soutien
de 40 millions d'euros accordés aux
banques alimentaires ou encore renfort
financier fléchi vers l'est se disent
mes chers collègues après de vote de ces
mesures d'urgence il nous faudra
préparer l'avenir nous pourrons pas
collectivement collectivement de
satisfaire dès qu'une crise survient
d'ouvrir les vannes de la dépense
publique en créant des chèques et des
ristournes
agir efficacement pour le pouvoir
d'achat c'est je le dis encourager le
travail combattre le chômage et lutter
contre le déficit de la balance
commerciale
c'est également mieux cibler les aides
et nous obliger à les rendre temporaire
c'est enfin parvenir un état plus agile
moins endettée est moindre et drogué par
la dépense publique
dans le texte de la cmp est à
l'initiative du sénat nous avons obtenu
deux mesures importantes à ce sujet
d'abord la craie la création d'une carte
vitale biométrique remèdes nécessaires
aux milliards d'euros de fraude qui
prive l'assurance maladie dans cette
capitale
d'autre part la suppression d'un
milliard d'euros même si nous en
demandions 4,5 de crédit sollicité par
le gouvernement mais non affectées à une
dépense précise c'est tout à la fois une
mesure d'économie efficace est un signe
de respect des assemblées parlementaires
mes chers collègues le second
quinquennat du président de la
république ouvre de nouvelles
perspectives pour la démocratie et pour
le sénat en témoignent de très
nombreuses dispositions issues de notre
chambre qui seront prochainement
promulguée et qui auront fait la loi
nous pouvons et nous devons nous réjouir
et continuer d'oeuvrer ensemble pour le
redressement économique et financier
notre pays
le groupe des républicains votre à deux
textes de ce plfr fruit de l'accord
trouvé hier en cmp je vous remercie
merci chers collègues
la parole est maintenant monsieur daniel
breuiller pour le groupe écologiste pour
cinq minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur général monsieur le ministre
chers collègues un texte rectificatif
est fait pour rectifier et nous
espérions qu il rectifia le tir
pour tenir compte des difficultés
incontestable auxquels font face les
françaises et les français les plus
modestes pour tenir compte des troubles
climatiques qui chaque jour sa cage
notre biodiversité des routes nos
agriculteurs assèche notaire ou encore
brûlent nos forêts pour tenir compte des
conséquences de la guerre en europe
menée par poutine pour une stratégie
énergétique sobre et d'avenir vous aviez
cette possibilité monsieur le ministre
avec ce projet rectificatif vous aviez
ce pouvoir vous aviez même pour le
groupe écologiste de voir il y eut des
rectifications et des mesures bienvenues
même si elle reste très inférieure à
l'inflation il y à une rectification que
nous voulons saluer c'est celle que la
cmp a apporté en rétablissant l'aide
exceptionnelle de rentrer aux
bénéficiaires des minima sociaux que
nous revendiquions et dont nous étions
atterrés que notre majorité sénatoriale
voy la supprimer mais pour le reste
qu'en est il vraiment je vais prendre
quatre exemples pour les étudiants ils
sont parmi les plus malmenés par la
crise vous ne les aidez pas pas assez ou
trop peu ils rencontrent des difficultés
pour se loger se nourrir se soigner pour
revaloriser les bourses mais pas du tout
à la hauteur de l'inflation les crous
vont devoir faire face à l'augmentation
des prix les universités sont au bord de
l'asphyxié avec des moyens de plus en
plus contraints et des difficultés
structurelles importantes
souvent avec des bâtiments énergivores
étudier est un droit ce n'est pas un
privilège l'éducation la jeunesse et
l'enseignement supérieur sont des
investissements nécessaires pour notre
pays avant d'être une dépense ils
devraient être valorisés pour les
collectivités qui nous sont chères votre
stratégie est incompréhensible comme le
dénonce d'ailleurs l'association des
maires de france certes vous consentez
une augmentation de trois et demi du
point d'indicé bienvenu bien
qu'inférieure à l'inflation certes vous
ajouter 600 millions très utile aux
collectivités qui viennent d'ailleurs
des discussions au sénat et qui aideront
peut-être à maintenir dans le giron de
la majorité les sénateurs centristes
mais vous prévoyez aussi une réduction
des dépenses de fonctionnement des
collectivités de 0 5% par an sur la
période 2000 22 2027 dans le pacte de
stabilité
alors oui vous avez rétropédaler dans
une formule très claire du ministre
béchu qui y voient une modération des
dépenses de fonctionnement pour qu'elle
augmente en moyenne annuelle de 0 5% de
moins que leurs tendances actuelles
cette phrase est très clair mais moi je
suis plus direct cette modération est
une baisse et rien de plus pour
l'audiovisuel public vous avez été dans
l'impréparation la plus totale et le
dispositif auquel on aboutit est
instable je retiens la proposition de
madame la ministre imams d'ulm halak de
débat national numérisons pas le savoir
la culture la création en laissant la
main aux plateformes et aux chaînes
privées pour l'accord pour l'écologie
l'accord gouvernement et l'eire qui a
présidé aux résultats de cette cmp est
un accord perdant-perdant pour
l'écologie deux propositions de notre
groupe avait obtenu un vote favorable
l'article 1a a pour réactiver un crédit
d'impôts pour les pme réalisant des
travaux énergétiques cher alain richard
et l'arctique de terre créant une
dotation climat financer d'une fraction
de thé icpe pour les collectivités ayant
conclu un contrat de relance est
transition écologique ces deux mesures
indispensables mais avons le encore
modestes n'ont même pas été conservé en
cmp que d'occasions manquées notre
modèle charge déficit public de 20
milliards et ne prend rien aux
profiteurs de crise qui bénéficient de
dizaines de milliards non l'imposer nous
ne comprenons pas que l'on se prive de
la ressource de taxation des supers
profits à l'heure où nos services
publics sont mises à mal l'union
centriste défend des ces mesures de bon
sens que sur les bancs de la gauche et
des écologistes
nous portons avec conviction et
constance depuis toujours j'entendais
parler ce matin de la stratégie de
dialogue et de compromis comme si
c'était une opportunité le compromis est
hélas à ce jour c'est clair et lisible
l'accord entre deux visions libéral et
sceller la vôtre monsieur le ministre et
celle des républicains vous êtes revenu
sur des fondamentaux comme la question
du temps de travail vous monétiser le
temps libre au risque de la santé des
salariés vous en exclu et les
partenaires sociaux vous avez aussi
choisi de subventionner autant les
week-ends en suv plutôt que de réserver
les aides aux salariés qui n'ont d'autre
choix que l'utilisation de leur véhicule
pour travailler pas d'investissements
non plus dans les alternatives douce
c'est navrant nos propositions demeure
même si ici certains préfèrent nous
chahuté plutôt que nous écouter les
scientifiques ont lancé avant-hier
encore un nouvel appel face à la gravité
des crises à venir rené dumont était
moqué lorsqu'il annonçait en 74 au
conclure je conclus avec rené dumont en
74 la crise de l'eau aujourd'hui nous
sommes en sécheresse généralisée mais
vous refusez toujours d'écouter les
alertes écologique merci sa collègue la
parole est maintenant à la présidente
eliane assassi pour le groupe crc eux
ce président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues la séquence dédiée aux
mesures de pouvoir d'achat se clôt ici
au sénat dans une confusion budgétaire
et un déficit démocratique budgétaire
car le parlement a rejeté pour la
seconde fois de son histoire la loi de
règlement pour 2021 ainsi contrairement
à ce que vient de dire monsieur ministre
conformément à l'article 40 air de la
lolf la prochaine loi de finances ne
pourra être examiné sans un vote positif
du parlement sur les comptes de la
nation pour 2021 les manipulations
comptables du gouvernement sont apparues
au grand jour il n'y a pas de trésor de
guerre de surplus de recettes cacher
pour preuve le solde budgétaire nique en
excédent de 2,6 milliards d'euros par
rapport aux prévisions un déficit
démocratique
car à l'issue du conclave de la cmt la
cuvée blanche entérine le rapprochement
du gouvernement et de la droite
sénatoriale
satisfaisant aussi et ainsi le
rassemblement national et ses députés
les débats parlementaires ont été
présentés par des accords préalables des
accords de couloir au détriment de la
transparence démocratique des débats
dans l'hémicycle les superbes les
surprofits indécents des multinationales
ne serviront pas financer les tpe et pme
en bout de chaîne elle qui comme nos
compatriotes sont frappés de plein fouet
par la spéculation et la course aux
profits l'audiovisuel public et son
indépendance constitutionnellement
garantis sont maintenant menacés par la
suppression de la redevance quand
l'accord entre les droites passe la
justice fiscale et les services publics
trépasse pourtant à l'issue de la
séquence électorale une partie du peuple
n'a pas opté pour ce projet politique
vous n'en tenez pas compte les deux lois
sur le pouvoir d'achat comporte des
avares ion l'inflation augmente sur un
an de 6,1 pour cent sans qu'aucune des
mesures prises ne préservent
intégralement le pouvoir d'achat de nos
concitoyennes et nos concitoyens ces
deux points de pouvoir d'achat perdu
pour les allocataires des minima sociaux
ces 2,5 points perdus en plus ils sont
locataires au prix fait au profit des
rentes privée au cours des dettes de ces
débats nous n'avons eu de cesse de vous
proposer les mesures alternatives à même
d'enrayer la spirale inflationniste
parce que c'est un impôt insidieux sur
les ménages modestes et les classes
moyennes nous continuons de porter le
local des prix à la pompe sur les
factures d'énergie des loyers et des
produits alimentaires de première
nécessité
le consensus des droites à évacuer avec
un certain mépris la question des
salaires en revanche il s'est agit d'
inventer toutes les mesures accessoires
à la rémunération du travail avec une
constante aucune des contributions des
entreprises ne sont obligatoires alors
selon leur bon vouloir elles pourront
verser la prime à cromwell pourront
doubler le montant de l'aide carburant à
leurs salariés elles pourront augmenter
de quelques centimes l'équité restaurant
en somme aucune obligation mais cela ne
vous suffit pas les travailleurs sont
quittes pour sacrifier leur droit au
repos avec une remise en cause sans
précédent des 35 heures par la
monétisation de leurs rtt ce sont les
salariés les plus précaires qui faute de
mieux devront concéder sous la pression
du patronat leurs jours de repos le
rehaussement du plafond des heures
supplémentaires est encore une temps une
entorse faite au code du travail en
somme la morale libéral institut le
travail est plus faute de gagner plus
ensuite la droite sénatoriale dans une
forme de surenchère dramatique oppose
les allocataires des minima sociaux aux
travailleurs pauvres sert l'on crée un
clivage nauséabond et factice entre les
bons citoyens et ceux qui ne prendrait
pas part à l'activité économique de la
nation la négation de ce qu'est la
réalité du marché de l'emploi est
coupable en 2021 près de 15 millions de
contrats de moins de moins d'un mois ont
été signés représentent 64 % des
embauches réalisées dès lors comment
avez vous osé proposer une réduction de
quelques euros aux allocataires du rsa
comment avez vous osé exclure d'un
chèque plus de 4 millions de foyers
pauvres
1,8 million d'étudiants dont un tiers
vivent sous le seuil de pauvreté la cmp
est revenue sur cette disposition unique
sans pour autant garantir le montant de
l'allocation versée enfin le fameux
miracle républicain pour soutenir nos
collectivités territoriales territoriale
n'a pas eu lieu ce simulacre d'accord
trouvé sur la compensation de la
revalorisation du point d'indicé de
là-haut du rsa de la hausse du prix des
énergies et des denrées alimentaires
s'indigne de la chambre qui prétend
représenter les collectivités
territoriales alors qu'elles sont déjà
privés de leurs recettes fiscales
vous portez là un nouveau coup à leur
libre administration par la non
compensation de décisions prises par
l'état central la conclusion de ces
débats ne fait que des perdants les
privilèges et pluri sont préservés
renforcée comment ne pas voir un symbole
effectivement quand cet échec
parlementaire sociales et démocratiques
intervient 4 août deux cent trente trois
ans plus tard les droite s'accordent
pour abolir les soi-disant soi-disant
privilèges des allocataires des minima
sociaux et des travailleurs pauvres sans
intervention du corps social l'accord
entre la droite et le gouvernement qui
prend forme sous nos yeux sap râle
sapera les uns après les autres les
intérêts des classes populaires
merci la parole est maintenant madame
sylvie vermeillet pour le groupe union
centriste pour cinq minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur général
mes chers collègues la commission mixte
paritaire qui s'est tenue hier soir a
abouti à un accord je tiens ici à
féliciter les deux rapporteurs généraux
pour leur travail efficace et
constructif dans un temps si contraint
le groupe union centriste à aborder
l'examen de ce premier projet de loi de
finances rectificative de l'année 2022
avec une doctrine claire et cohérente
privilégier les mesures temporaires et
ciblées en conciliant justice sociale et
réduction de la dette nous avons soumis
à la discussion plusieurs propositions
en ce sens les motifs de regrets demeure
à cet égard et la perspective déjà
proche du projet de loi de finances pour
2023 sera l'occasion de revenir à la
charge
je pense bien sûr un autre amendement
portant création d'une contribution
exceptionnelle de solidarité sur les
super profits
le refus d'adopter une telle mesure
détonne avec les propos du secrétaire
général de l'onu antonio guterres est ce
qui a appelé hier je cite tous les
gouvernements à taxer ses profits
excessifs et à utiliser les fonds pour
soutenir les plus vulnérables en ces
temps difficiles
demander un effort de solidarité
provisoire aux entreprises qui ont
engendré des bénéfices exceptionnels
alors même que l'état a subventionné
massivement l'économie dans le cadre de
l'épidémie de coville est juste ce qui
est démagogique ce sont 6 1 pour
différer et non consenti capelle ras le
remboursement de notre dette publique
la proposition portée par le président
laurent lafon de reporter la suppression
de la contribution à l'audiovisuel
public répondait aussi à ce problème
précis nous appelions de nos voeux une
large concertation avec le monde de la
culture car remplacer au pied levé lassé
happé par une fraction de tva ne règle
pas la question de l'avenir de l'audio
visuel public de même la proposition
défendue par notre collègue michel
canevet oignons du groupe union
centriste sur le financement des frais
de carburant répondait-elle à cette
philosophie cibler les aides sur ceux
qui en ont le plus besoin de manière à
la fois plus équitable et moins
dispendieuse pour la bonne tenue des
comptes publics prolonger la remise de
carburant au bénéfice de tous les
automobilistes fusse-t-il belge l'ubs
luxembourgeois ou suisse pour un coût de
l'ordre de quatre milliards et demi nous
apparaît peu compatible avec la fin
annoncée du quoi qu'il en coûte au moins
avons nous pu impulser un débat nourri
et il faut le dire de haute tenue tout
au long de ces deux jours et deux nuits
de séance avec la quasi-certitude est la
satisfaction d'y revenir à l'automne car
il y a peu de chances que la dette nous
oublie mais nous avons aussi des motifs
de satisfaction bien évidemment la
dotation de soutien en faveur des
communes et de leurs groupements les
plus fragiles financièrement et les plus
affectées par la revalorisation du point
d'indicé de la fonction publique et par
la hausse des prix de l'énergie le
groupe union centriste défendez un
bouclier tarifaire communal il se
réjouit d'avoir obtenu par le veau d'un
sous amendement présenté par notre
président hervé marseille l'extension de
la mesure proposée par notre rapporteur
général le dispositif final porte à 600
millions d'euros le concours apporté aux
collectivités en iran dans dorénavant
éligibles plus de la moitié des communes
la cmp d'hier soir à sauver cette mesure
est essentielle pour nos collectivités
et je remercie donc notre rapporteur
général notre président de commission
ainsi que l'ensemble des collègues
sénateurs qui sur ce sujet on fait peur
preuve d'une solidarité même pas en rêve
pour l'assemblée nationale
félicitons nous donc de cette
compensation à la hauteur des
difficultés rencontrées par les
collectivités du bloc communal et pour
cette raison déterminante le groupe
union centriste adoptera dans sa très
grande majorité
ce plfr je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant aux présidents jean claude
requier pour le groupe rds ce pour cinq
minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur remporté en général
mais sa colère après la lecture des
conclusions seront posées douadi pouvoir
là ça hier deux gamines ont aujourd'hui
ce volet budgétaire il s'agissait bien
de deux textes distincts même si
d'aucuns ont pu y est conforme à l
examen et à evry partie gealan reçu la
visite à mon tour de cette nuit ses
commissions mixtes conclusive qui
au-delà nous éviter encore on débat à
l'issue incertaine quand on a pu
l'observer justement y est avec l'urgent
est inédit depuis 1833 et morts suivi de
la loi de règlement qui permettra une
entrave vigueur dans les pyrénées de ce
texte pour soutenir le niveau de vie est
fragile et en être certain nombre de
mesures d'urgence voire souvent
l'interné âgé tic ainsi que le soutien à
l'ukraine
on est au niveau gardés ce et salue le
maintient en ciel me permanent à notre
collègue jallieu hawks pour la fier à la
lavande qui a remporté un bon consensus
danse notre assemblée
je regarde néanmoins que quand des
millions des banques alimentaires n'ont
quant à eux pas été retenus
après relecture osorio aussi inspiré
meilleurs succès pour nos propositions
de compensation collectivités locales de
lance du point d'indicé des
fonctionnaires ou encore de la
revalorisation des rémunérations dues à
domicile ainsi que pour saint pierre et
miquelon
il relaie mais leur soutien à
l'agriculture
durement frappé l'année passée chéres
ayez andy et pour la territorialisation
des mesures comme la lutte contre hausse
du prix des carburants
la réforme du financement de biens
publics et n est point important de ce
texte c'est un sujet déjà ancien mais
auquel il va manquer encore l'impulsion
politique nécessaire
nous voyons néanmoins gas que c'était
audiovisuel public continue de
bénéficier des financements
allez quoi tu à son bon fonctionnement
la renationalisation
d'edf et entrevoit les majeures je ne
reviendrai pas sur marque déjà fait
la lecture jeunes en tout cas ce père et
mère voit une nouvelle dégradation du
sol depuis mis depuis les 15 milliards
d'euros jusqu'à quand pourra-t-on
contini revient c'est déficit accumulé à
l'heure à l'heure de la remontée des
taux d'intérêt espérons que la
croissance sera au rendez vous et 8e ra
des hausses d'impôts à l'avenir le
groupe rdse
votera donc pour adoption de ce plfr en
conclusion je voudrais une fois de plus
salué le travail des rapports cas
général la bonne tenue de nos débats et
le sérieux de discussion règne de
l'ambiance soit électrique d'assemblée
nationale
aurait changé sur au sénat nous n'avons
pas de braillards virage et
[Applaudissements]
merci merci monsieur le président
requier de ce commentaire finale
aller dernier orateur inscrit monsieur
rémi féraud pour le groupe socialiste
pour cinq minutes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre shark collègues la commission
mixte paritaire sur le budget
rectificatif a été conclusive sans
surprise temps et cela a été exprimé la
convergence est évidente entre la
majorité présidentielle et la majorité
sénatoriale sur une orientation libérale
dont le budget rectificatif porte la
marque cela a au moins un mérite c'est
celui de la clarification
alors avec le texte pouvoir d'achat ce
plfr forme à tous et mes collègues
socialistes et moi même nous ne sommes
pas dans l'opposition systématique
puisque nous nous sommes abstenus avec
beaucoup de réserves sur le premier
texte mais l'essentiel de la politique
du gouvernement allait dans le deuxième
texte le budget rectificatif sur lequel
nous allons nous prononcer
définitivement aujourd'hui hélas notre
vote contre et et reste sans réserve
pourquoi parce que les avancées pour les
collectivités locales mais aussi je veux
le souligner le soutien à l'aide
alimentaire notamment ne masque pas les
graves reculs sociaux
l'injustice profonde et le risque
démocratique que contient ce texte et ce
encore plus après la discussion
parlementaire qu'avant reculs sociaux
non seulement il n'y a pas le compte en
matière de pouvoir d'achat car les
augmentations prévues restent en deçà de
l'inflation mais en plus le détricotage
du droit du travail est à l'oeuvre sans
avoir fait l'objet d'aucune concertation
sociale et pour les français c'est
perdant perdant perdant en termes de
qualité de vie faute de vouloir
augmenter vraiment les salaires perdants
en termes de ressources publiques pour
financer la protection sociale et les
services publics du fait des mécanismes
de désocialisation et de défiscalisation
et le compromis entre vous sur un
bornage du dispositif afin 2025 se
rapproche en réalité bien plus du
principe de pérennisation vole voulu par
la majorité sénatoriale
tu as une mesure exceptionnelle liée à
la période de très forte inflation qui
est elle censée durer seulement jusqu'en
profonde injustice ensuite que ce budget
rectificatif et s'accommode trop bien de
l'injustice fiscale au détriment des
finances publiques et aux bénéfices du
capital depuis cinq ans jamais depuis
des décennies les inégalités de
patrimoine dans notre pays n'ont été
aussi grande et pourtant vous continuez
à refuser tout rééquilibrage fiscales
efficaces en faisant contribuer les plus
aisés même pas les multinationales qui
tirent un profit incroyable de la
situation actuelle des prix de l'énergie
17 milliards d'euros de profits en un
semestre pour total energy vraiment en
cet été 2011 22 au début du un nouveau
quinquennat quelle occasion manquée
car la taxation des supers profits
beaucoup d'autres pays que la france y
viennent sous une forme ou sous une
autre même le secrétaire général de
l'onu a plaidé en ce sens avec force
hier combien de temps la france
va-t-elle rester à cons recourant
songer aux symboles que nous aurions
plus envoyer si ce refus de taxer les
milliards de bénéfices exceptionnels
réalisés par les géants du pétrole ou
des transports si en plus de cela nous
avions maintenu en cmp votre amendement
de suppression d'une allocation
exceptionnelle de rentrer 200 euros pour
les plus modestes de nos concitoyens les
bénéficiaires du rsa ou les étudiants
boursiers songer aux symboles que nous
aurions envoyé si l'amendement présenté
par le groupe ait l'air pour rogner le
rsa de 3 euros par mois avait été votée
dans le texte précédent
risque démocratique
enfin la suppression
précipité de la redevance audiovisuelle
sans alternative juste pérenne avec un
montant financier suffisant garantie
elle fragilise l'indépendance de
l'audiovisuel public dans notre pays et
vous conviendrez avec bon sens qu'ont vu
de la situation est encore plus 1 4 août
il y avait plus urgent ce à taxer les
super profits des multinationales
car remplacer la redevance télé par un
impôt injuste
et pourtant vous avez décidé de faire le
contraire dans quelques années quand
nous verrons les conséquences comme
c'est le cas aujourd'hui en espagne de
la suppression de la redevance télé vous
verrez que beaucoup se demanderont
pourquoi nous avons fait ça aujourd'hui
alors nous regrettons vraiment de ne pas
avoir réussi à vous convaincre de
procéder autrement et d'y travailler
sereinement dans les mois prochains
aujourd'hui sans réserve et en
conclusion les sénateurs du groupe
socialistes écologistes et républicains
voteront contre le projet de loi de
finances rectificative je vous remercie
merci chers collègues
conformément à l'article 42 alinéa 12 du
règlement je veux mettre voit l'ensemble
du projet de loi de finances
rectificative pour 2022 dans la
rédaction résultant du texte élaboré par
la cmp modifié par les amendements du
gouvernement il va être procédé dans les
conditions prévues par l'article 56 du
règlement au scrutin public sur
l'ensemble du projet de loi le scrutin
est ouvert
personne ne demande à voter le scrutin
est clos
or
344 exprimé 330 pour 233 contre
le projet de loi de finances
rectificative est adopté mes chers
collègues
je constate que le sénat ait puisé son
ordre du jour pour la session
extraordinaire
monsieur le président du sénat a reçu de
monsieur le premier ministre
communication du décret de monsieur le
président de la république portant
clôture de la session extraordinaire du
parlement en conséquence il est pris
acte de la clôture de la session
extraordinaire
je vais lever la séance on vous
remerciant de votre présence en ce 4
août prochaines séances le mardi 4
octobre 14h30 pour le débat sur les
états généraux de la justice la séance
est levée
[Applaudissements]